front lines and i always say this
there's a lot of people
who fanatize fantasize and and think
about
maybe romanticize it actually think
about
standing next to dr king you know
everybody right around january
everybody's like
you know i wish i was standing right
next to dr king and marching with him
well let me tell you
if you're even marching right now you
ain't marching with dr king
if you ain't coming out here you
wouldn't be out with dr king
don't be acting like you would be
because many people during that time
were not supporting dr king many people
were calling him a radical
many people were calling for his arrest
many people were calling that he was too
much
we are too much right now
so i'm gonna tell you we don't just show
up folks
we don't just show up we don't just take
pictures on instagram and think we did
something
i'm gonna tell you something every
single
elected official needs to hear
from you if they've been elected
and they got your vote whether they got
your vote or not they need to hear from
you
because trust me that you hear from them
don't they send you the little flyer
don't you get a flyer from them don't
they knock on the door
aren't they really nice when they're
trying to get your vote but right now
where are they at
where are they at but i'm telling you
when people are organized
when people do that pressure you could
do that so if you're watching right now
you couldn't be out here for some reason
or not i want to let you know
that you could right you could tweet at
governor walsh right now
you could tweet mayor elliot right now
you could tweet
at all of the elected officials and let
them know how you feel
and in fact you can get a group of
people and start tweeting at people
and also to eat at the media too because
they love to take a picture
of a looted store but not a peaceful
protester putting his fist up
they love to put up some damaged
property but not
interview those neighbors who have been
traumatized by this government
call them out too call them out
uh and also for i'm sorry
uh and for all the folks that have been
arrested first of all i'm gonna ask you
uh that phone is gonna be useful so pull
it out for a second i'm gonna make it
work do something we do some matching
with that phone for a second
okay the first thing is i want you to
text this number
uh the number six one two two hundred
two five five zero and then text
the number eight to it so i'm gonna say
the number again six one two
two hundred two five five zero
and then text eight to it and you're
gonna get an automatic link that link
is actually a link that will send you
directly
to eight nine bills actually that we
have been trying to pass
especially since last summer that have
been put together by the coalition
and that many people are interested in
passing now i heard you know now all
sudden they
want to talk about these bills but
people have been trying to get their
attention
uh to get those bills so six one two
two hundred two five five zero and then
text a tool you should get an automatic
link
and then i want you to make sure now
that that you get a chance that when you
send the link when you see that link
you get a chance to review those bills
but most importantly you get a chance to
actually
submit an email right now to your
elected official
and let them know that not only you care
about those bills and and you will get a
chance
you will get a chance that you can add
some language to it
okay some fiery language at the top of
that already
nicely crafted email for you we need to
do that not just one day
we need to just keep doing it until they
cannot function that they can't see
any other name other than dante wright
george floyd
and the countless stolen lives they need
to see that and hear that from you
and for all the other people right now
if you want to call governor walls
here's the number
all right six one two make it make a
dial and then you know later on just be
like
call actually call him and just be like
let him hear where we at
six one six five one two zero one
three four zero zero
and you could always uh email him too
it's tim dot walls at state dot
mn dot u s
six five one two zero one three four
zero zero
maybe we need to sing it so you remember
six
five one two zero one three four zero
zero
tim waltz statement.us
and then uh the the for for the folks
for everybody else i'm gonna just give
you these numbers as well uh this is the
public safety commission in john
five one two zero one seven one six
zero and then the state commander
uh who's been commanding uh this mess
here
um commander langler six five one
two zero one seven one zero zero
all right and then here's what i'm gonna
ask you most of you are part of some
group
some fake facebook group maybe it's real
uh
some some whatsapp group some text
messaging group
some friends they're about to go eat
somewhere whatever that group is
send something to them okay send
something to them
this is a moment where we need to build
out we need to reach
out to everybody a lot of people right
now i just heard about the killing of
dante right
but they don't know what to do they're
thinking they're just going to send us
some sympathies i'm tired of sympathies
i'm tired of condolencing i'm tired of
just saying i'm sorry
i'm tired of people saying oh this was
just one time
it's been happening it's been happening
we got to do
something we got to do something you
know when coven hit
everybody was asking when that vaccine
was coming out nobody was asking about
how they want to be sympathetic
everybody was like how do we fix this
how do we reopen how do we get out
i want to get out i want to do something
what can we do when it came to the
oldest injustice system in this country
from the genocide of native americans
and to mass incarceration and slavery
and today where we live in
and by the way back then there was
a fire hose it was
sending dogs at you but now they got a
little smarter
they'd be sending the those uh flash
bangs
you can't see that much right and then
they'd be sending that that tear gas
it's the same brutality the same
brutality
the same walls the same fences the same
government
the same people mil using their own
military
against peaceful protesters who are just
saying stop
killing us stop
killing us stop killing
us stop killing us
stop killing us stop
killing us all of them should be going
home
all of them should be going home they
think somehow that building is important
it ain't important it's taxpayer dollar
building
the helmet you're wearing we paid for it
the badge you got
we paid for it the lights you see we
paid for it
this street is our street this is
our country our city our people
[Music]
and you work for us but we made one
mistake
and we ain't gonna make it again we
elected people who put you in power
we're gonna unelect them so that we have
the real people
in power that's what we need to do
because those people who put you there
who made you protect the building are
you kidding me
what's inside that building other than
oppression what's inside that building
other than
what you've done to decriminalize poor
people in brooklyn center
what is inside that building other than
a legacy
of putting black people incarceration
what is inside that building other than
paperwork made by police officers who
don't see
me who don't value me who don't believe
in black lives matter so what are you
talking about that building there's
nothing inside that building
we're out here the heartbeats out here
there are children out here i see some
children out here
standing out here we took over at their
playground we took her over there
their their their law those families
right here who are here right now
who you last night were brought a siege
on them
you brought a siege on them but i'm
gonna tell you something folks
i'm gonna tell you something
the days that we were silent is over
the days that we're silent is over and
the days that they kill one of our
brothers and sisters and we don't show
up is over
you see what happened as soon as dante
wright was killed people
from the neighborhood showed up youth
from the neighborhood showed up
people across the city showed up and we
continued to show up and guess what
started to happen
we got the city manager fire
[Applause]
and the police chief thought he was
going to stick around
he even left on his own he was ready to
get the hell out
he's out and then the officer thought
somehow
we forgot about her not only has she
been fired but at least now some charges
have been brought against her
and we are demanding more charges by the
way because it is definitely
it's definitely not enough and we all
know that we want
murder we want murder charges what do we
want
murder charges murder charges because
what she did to dante
right was murder it was murder
it was murder it was murder how is it
possible
that mahmoud noor gets charged with
murder and she is
[Applause]
i'm gonna tell you now as i conclude
i'm a believer in faith and i'm fasting
right now
and i believe i'm a little closer to god
right now in this moment because i'm
fasting
and i'm gonna ask god one thing oh god
you have shown us that in times of
oppression we believe in you
we believe in your power and we believe
in you and we believe that in this
moment right now
a lot of people's hearts are connected
to dante right
dante's family and a lot of people are
in pain right
now and i personally believe deep down
in my hearts when we come together we
can move mountains and we're going to
move mountains
we're going to move mountains today is a
little bit dampy
today is a little bit cold but there's a
warm coming up
this summer is going to get warm it's
going to get sunny this grass is going
to come out of these green light
these trees are going to become more
green and when that happens
i personally believe that we're going to
win and not only win for dante wright
but for many people
we're going to win for children who are
not born yet we're going to create a
better
community safer community and we're
going to do that together
we're going to do that together and as i
conclude i want you to take
a half a second a half a second maybe a
minute
look to the person on your right look to
the person on your left
i want you to recognize these are your
brothers in this movement
and your sisters in this movement and
they have been there
they have been there you have been each
other and look at
people from all walks of life all faiths
all colors
all backgrounds we are here together
united for one thing
justice justice justice say it with me
justice
justice justice justice
justice justice justice
justice and we're gonna get that we're
gonna get that and if there are any
muslims in here
you know our chant we believe in god so
stay with me
okay allah so somebody i was like look
i'm gonna tell you
la wagon is very powerful and and
there's a
special message going down over there
too
all right allah
and i am with this as i always do we
will demand
justice by any means necessary
[Applause]
black lives
[Applause]
who shut this down who shut this down
who shut this down who shut this down
say it's me says me
says
[Music]
tired of watching black people die
because that's the question i'm not
asking for no justice no more
what they justin's gonna do for us at
this point
they're just gonna keep killing us
they're just gonna keep killing us
i mean i am not violent to those who are
not violent to me
i am not violent for those who are not
violent to me
i'm out here living life black happy
doing what i'm supposed to do
and you're killing people over air
freshener you killing people because
they're on drugs
you killing people because they license
to carry you killing people
day in and day out and you're standing
up here and you're acting like we're the
problem when y'all been the problem
but i started off with slave penalties
if you angry y'all
i'm not talking peaceful y'all i'm not
talking peaceful i'm not talking people
if you talking people that's you that is
you
talking people i'm not talking people
it's it's been the time
they've been killing us we've been dead
we're gonna continue
to be dead we need to strategize y'all
we need to bridge together y'all we need
to get together y'all
and we really really need to talk about
what it's time to talk about
it's bedtime i love y'all i love black
people i love
black people i love black people
and if you ain't black and you don't
love black people that's a problem for
me
that's a [ __ ] problem for me
i am here today i'm not trying to take
too much time
because there's nothing else to talk
about how many times i gotta say stop
killing her
how many times i gotta stop how many
times do i have to cry
how many times y'all gonna say comply
comply you might live when we know four
steps being black is a death sentence
it's a justice so
i am not violent to those who are not
violent to me so if y'all see something
y'all hear something i was not violent
i was not resisting arrest i'm just
tired
of them telling us that's
it that's um i don't want to talk about
the the the the people the officials
they know what's the [ __ ] going on
they know what the [ __ ] they need to be
doing they know what it is
they know where we at they know already
so it's no point of asking permission
how many times can i breathe
can i breathe can i breathe i'm gonna
breathe i'm gonna
breathe body is necessary my enemy is
necessary
i'm gonna breathe my son's gonna breathe
my man will breathe
my dad gonna be free my kids
don't breathe and that's for me
and that's on me
oh black people shout you fall
bro
bro i'm done
i'm done asking for commission i'm done
hear me
i'm done i'm done asking for permission
i'm not violent to those who are not
bothering me they out there killing us
they're out here beating us they're out
here locking us up they out here
stripping our families away they're out
here down
they doing the most they're doing the
most
so at this point we have to match energy
that's what we have to do we have to
match the energy
[Applause]
so we got one of the elders in the
building from the bpp
give him a big round of applause
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the name of allah the most beneficent
the most merciful
the most merciful benefactor the most
merciful
redeemer all praise is due to allah
the guardian the evolver the cherisher
and the sustainer of all of the worlds
i bear witness that none deserves the
rights of worship there's none
deserving the right to be conformed to
except the law sopano at the island
and i bear witness to every prophet that
has been raised by the divine power of
the world
that came from adam until muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
we preach your dear beloved brothers and
sisters to the greeting words of peace
that is written in the quran and all
people who say peace
hotep we say assalamu alaikum
the peace be unto you black power
black power and a strong black military
we can black to call today
for black power but we know there's an
issue
that frederick douglass related to an
issue that marcus musaya davi
related to there's an issue that the
honorable elijah muhammad related to
martin and malcolm declared a certain
form of freedom
but that freedom was not actualized by
dr king
malcolm nor elijah muhammad those today
jesse jackson al sharpton all of the
leaders from td
jake's on i don't wait to see who's
going to be at bat
but i'm on first base black power like
power
and if he butts or hits that home run
i'm hauling ass to second base
because i'm going to bring as many home
as possible
but dr king said that until we solve the
issue
until we stop the issue of police
brutality
there will be no freedom for black
people in america that's right
we have been divinely prepared our
brother jermaine
we have our beloved brother and our
sister who is organized sister my alicia
i don't know where she is sister militia
and we are organizing strongly against
police brutality
and we will be able to stop it we have
been divinely prepared by the lord of
all the worlds
from the honorable knack turner to this
very hour
there have been a plea for freedom and
to stop the police brutality
dr king himself was a victim of police
brutality
we have organized today under the
leadership of our attorney
and the doctor malik zulu shabazz we
stand in
black power like power we stand on the
leadership the honorable hashing that
cannot
enzynga who have formulas legal formulas
the community faith-based initiative is
what we will use
to stop the police brutality we have to
take
the freedom in our hand the justice in
our hand and manage it for ourselves
dr king said you must use the money
and the wealth and manage it with your
hands malcolm x is telling you the
health the medicine
the politics the science the education
must be
in your hands then you may have a form
of black nationalism but you will not be
free
until you stop the police brutality like
power
like power i am the shaky man by
abdullah kareem
i am the national spokesman for the new
black panther party for self defense
the audible huey p newton said you
either
arm yourself or you harm yourself
like power the doctor and the attorney
and dr khaled after muhammad said your
god and your gun
you have to be prepared to protect your
black people at this hour
you must be willing to march why did
they kill the baby girls and the church
black king was asked
they killed the babies in the church
because you failed to activate
he called you to activation he called
you to mass protest
against tyranny against oppression until
there's no more tyranny and no more
oppression on the land
but don't you know that no great nation
will tell you can kill a black man
a black woman or our black children with
no due process
that a great nation would never allow
for that form of injustice
you can't read because you're black you
can't vote because you're black you
can't sit on that park bench
because you're black you can't swim in a
white man's ocean front property
nor his swimming pool a few years ago
you were set up for lynching
for swimming in a white man's swimming
pool they would drain that damn pool and
then put clorox in that pool
and say it wasn't fit for whites to swim
in if a black man went in the swimming
pool
that's the degenerated form that has
been inherited
from andrew johnson on to this hour the
degenerated form of dehumanization
that has been done to us and some
horrible things have been done to us
brother and sister
but i here to submit to you that we will
stop it police brutality
will stop when we stop it what do we
want
and when do we want it yeah and how we
gonna take it by any
means necessary what do you want and
when do we want it
and tell me how we're gonna take it
[Applause]
[Applause]
the white men only had a temporary visa
are only a squad is right for a short
period of time
the squadron's rights have run out i'm
straight out of the tribe of the
blackfoot
and the plantation of the honorable nat
turner and i'm here to tell you my chief
told the pilgrim eventually it treated
to plant corn
and hunt buffalo but then go and go
meaning to leave the land
this is our land that abraham lincoln
borrowed right the next state in
illinois
in missouri he bought it from harriet
tubman the descendants of not turner
the descendants of the honorable
frederick douglass
even wooden 245 nicknamed donald
duck trump referred to frederick
douglass and frederick douglass
was a man who said this is as i close to
you tonight
frederick douglass said to organize
against the opposition
frederick douglass said to find the
discipline and organize against
undiscipline
he said to find the peacemaker and
organize
against the war among us but i'm telling
you today
the most important thing that i can tell
you the most important thing that i can
share with you
is that you beloved sister you pointed
to harriet tubman
and said your beloved sister the most
important thing you could do
is to organize against you having any
form of exclusion
but have participation in your own black
government
like power empower your own black
government the constitution the
declaration
the bill of rights he said first of all
you have to be right he has never been
right
no constitutional rights no inalienable
rights no
right to be that he would have to bow
down and submit to
thou shall not kill became a cliche all
of it became a cliche
and eventually that was it so i'm just
here to tell you
that we now as a black people must
declare
our freedom and take it and manage it in
your own hands
and know that the bill of rights none of
those are right
that the constitution he said none of us
are free until all of us are free
let's say together none of us are free
until all of us get free
i said none of us are free until all of
us get supreme
none of us are free until all of us get
you free
and your knowledge will prevent you from
ever being a slave
i didn't breach you as i came to you in
the name of allah the most beneficial
the most merciful
assalamu alaikum and black power
that power and the strong black military
to block the goddamn call
assalamu alaikum and black power
[Applause]
say her name say her name
say her name say her name
say her name say her name
say his name say his name
say his name say his name
say his name
so we got some candles
hello it is another sad day
but i think we have enough people
no matter what no matter what moment
because
what's more powerful than anything is
your voice your presence
and we have to remember that dante